well brian a special event is kicking
off to address covet vaccine concerns
right here in our community clark county
commissioner william mccurdy is hosting
a forum in the central valley tonight so
people can get all their questions
answered directly by medical experts
sasha loftis joins us live near kerry
and mlk with the latest hey sasha
christian good evening tonight's forum
is taking place so really anyone who has
any questions about the kovid 19 vaccine
can get those answered that form is set
to start here in just a few minutes you
can see a few medical experts here uh
talking ahead of when it is set to start
as people are getting here to attend now
the goal here i guess again is to
encourage everyone to get immunized and
protected now those medical experts you
saw there attending tonight include
several nurse practitioners and an
infectious disease expert anyone
attending can ask them questions
directly and participate in this
discussion for free the first 50 people
to show up also have the chance to get
their shot if they haven't already
received it we had the chance to speak
with commissioner mccurdy earlier
tonight about the importance of an event
like this
there's so much going on out there
there's a lot going on in the world of
social media especially and as much as
we can do to bring people in together in
a space and listen to health care
professionals about what cold vaccine is
and what it isn't i think that we're
going to move people closer to being
more comfortable with receiving the
vaccine
now again the form is free for everyone
it is set to kick off here in just a few
moments and lasts until eight tonight it
is here at the william pearson center
that's right near kerry and mlk if you
would like to attend we do have more
information for you on our website
8newsnow.com reporting live tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now